the way crypto bitcoin installed bitcoin
um
it's still in its infancy and until it
matures and really becomes more of a a
currency in a legitimate store of value
whichever one you you want to look at it
as
it's gonna trade mostly like a growth
stock it's gonna trade like a
speculative investment
and that means there's gonna be times
where it's risk on and a risk off right
now we're in a risk off environment
people are doing flights to safety
six months ago it was more risk on and
the hot money was going into things like
bitcoin and ethereum so that's part of
simply it was very much correlated with
the stock market as the stock market you
know stocks are going up bitcoin is
going up right
is there a business
metaphor for that something like that
where like you accomplish your goals as
a business yeah
yeah if you sort of figure it you know
what i mean like the gays accomplish the
goal right of equality right you can you
can get married you can adopt kids you
can have kids right through surrogacy
all of that stuff they
the quality it's here but then you don't
stop there must be like a business
version yeah facebook
that you just keep going like whatever
the hell is this
right let me tell you what the mission
was for him
there's a theory i have on this too that
organizations tend to become
exaggerations of what their values are
they exaggerate themselves over time
they're becoming more and more and more
extreme to what their core values are
they they become like strat and became
more crazy if it's crazy a little crazy
if it's crazy crazy crazy crazy yeah
woke becomes more well it always
exaggerates because this echo chamber
and the sort of effect that happens of
self-reinforcement surrounding yourself
with like-minded people the ultimate
echo chamber is facebook where they you
know skew the algorithms so you only see
what you want to see what you like to
hear so you
you know your beliefs are reinforced
i've watched my one of my my uh my third
wife just become
you know you know going into the whole
you know the cute thing because they fed
her this stuff on on facebook you know
and i think it's it's really screwed up
when i look at facebook like this the
values of that company are just so
[ __ ] up
and i don't think he'd probably start
off as a terrible guy
he wanted to get laid he even want to
get laid right and then like he just
like it became this gross exaggeration
of almost like an
orwellian sort of spoon feeding people
what you know they want to hear and what
you want them to hear at the same time
are you telling me you're not excited to
go into the metaverse led by humanoid
robot mark zuckerberg
the good thing about the metaverse is it
will not be led by mark zuckerberg
it will not be because by the nature of
the metaverse and everything about
blockchain it's a decentralizing force
so centralized institutions while
they'll play some role i i believe that
this next evolution is going to be away
from centralized institutions and we see
that right now happening in the
financial world with you have these new
platforms popping up like sushi swap and
pancakes these just names of
decentralized exchanges that 15 guys
will do more volume a 15-man company
decentralized can outperform coinbase
that has 8 000 or 15 000 employees it's
so much more elegant and effective and i
think that over time i don't think the
metaverse will be dominated by people
like zuckerberg i pray it's not
so you're pretty i know this obviously
but you're pretty bullish on on crypto
and and all that are you surprised that
bitcoin didn't move that much in the
last two months after what happened in
canada where they were freezing bank
accounts and you'd think that bitcoin
would have blown up and then all the
ukraine stuff and the swift system as
you mentioned before you'd think that
bitcoin right now or crypto in general
would all be skyrocketing but it's
actually not quite like that at the
moment so so the way crypto bitcoin
installed bitcoin
um
it's still in its infancy and until it
matures and really becomes more of a a
currency in a legitimate store of value
whichever one you you want to look at it
as
it's gonna trade mostly like a growth
stock it's going to trade like a
speculative investment
and that means there's going to be times
where it's risk on and risk off right
now we're in a risk off environment
people are doing flights to safety
six months ago it was more risk on and
the hot money was going into things like
bitcoin and ethereum so that's part of
simply it was very much correlated with
the stock market as the stock market you
know stocks are going up bitcoin is
going up right
and also it's like is that partly just
because people have more money then and
they're just like i'll just put more
money into bitcoin too because i have
more money partially but what's
happening is when people are
are scared
bitcoin is still not mature enough that
people look at it as a flight to safety
it's just not um
you know and that it was supposed to be
that and it probably will be that but
it's still not there yet and um and
bitcoin is still manipulated in other
words there's still some very big people
as [ __ ] with it right but i think
generally speaking right now i think
what you're seeing is that you've i
think it's healthy for bitcoins you have
this trading range
of like you know 35 whatever it is to
the high with 60 and that's okay and i
think it takes time like you know when
bitcoin crashed down to 3 000 or two
thousand dollars it stayed there for him
then ultimately it has another rally so
i think it's building a base right now
and then ultimately it will go
substantially higher i think this
pressure's
you know again that's just my
appointment tell you to buy because of
that but but but you know i think that
the nature of bitcoin the the scarcity
um
the stickiness that people tend to hold
for the long term
there's a lot of things that i think are
over the long term putting upward
pressure on the price what are you doing
with your money these days what like
what are you in this like crazy time
heavily into
into the crypto
defy
metaverse
um
very much into that and uh but i don't
have to invest my money so much it's not
what i do really my my my model is more
people will actually give me stakes in
their companies for for in exchange for
advice and and using my brand so i have
a very sort of very much of a risk-free
model of getting involved in companies
now when companies that are bigger and
more all saying the better deals
i'll put money in i don't mind doing
that but very often the more speculative
deals they're looking for advice they're
looking for to get connections opened up
to them um
so i do a lot of that and they also
invest in in the off blockchain world as
well i have a great iced tea company
that um i'm involved which is blowing up
right now so you know for me you can
pimp them out you can come on yeah well
there's nothing you can buy the product
you can buy the ic which is great it's
called mod talk yeah there you go kind
of unbelievable
yeah that's amazing it's great iced tea
it's all over the place and in the
northeast right now it'll go nationwide
this year you know throughout the year
um but you know
here's here's what here's what i believe
the safest best investment in the world
for anybody you want an investment tip
ready this buy the s p 500 in a van car
no load mutual fund
hold it reinvest the dividends and just
set it and forget it and that is your
best bet of all
so that does show me you're still
bullish on america to some degree right
well listen you know again i think that
america values
and it's global positioning and i said
the middle class is gonna get squeezed
but the 500 largest corporations
they're running this show anyway
they're behind those whole you know you
know military industrial complex i mean
they're in charge and you know what
you're doing is when you're buying that
you're buying the collective
ingenuity
of america and for all faults
the system is amazing what we have here
as an economic system
is powerful it rewards
hard work it rewards ingenuity um and
unlike other countries where success is
frowned on standing out is frowned on
here we we we worship or we emulate we
elevate people who have taken risks and
make a lot of money what would you do if
you were ceo one of these companies that
was going woke so if you were the head
of disney right now knowing everything i
know about you and now the company seems
like it's an upheaval and the board's
angry at you and people are boy i mean
it's hard to gauge how much of it's real
but if if you had a general sense of
what's going on right now and they're
coming to you what would you do
different than this guy i mean to say
this is my job yeah i i yeah because i i
would simply i would have what i would
have done and i would have never let it
get this far i would have been having
this i believe the problem
usually comes way before that it's like
this virus this cancer that's forming
and spreads and it spreads and it's
allowed to keep spreading and before you
know it the inmates are ruling the
asylum so i would have been you know
carefully or let's say almost daily
messaging you know things that were
against that whole thing supporting as
you know i feel about gay people
whatever but i would you know have a
very very different type of corporate
culture um but that said you know in the
way the world works right now it's
almost like you get canceled like that
yeah so you know
it's pretty high and mighty me to sell
stick to my core beliefs but you know i
might have to be forced specifically for
fiduciary response or i'd be fired as
the ceo for not pretending to be woke if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell